Hey it's me Destin, welcome back to Smarter Every Day
If there is one thing that I learnt from the backwards bicycle experiment
Is that knowledge is not understanding
So a couple of years ago when I made the YouTube series about helicopter physics
I gained the knowledge of how they worked, but not really the understanding
so today on Smarter Every Day
I'm going to try hover a helicopter
I've heard its the hardest thing you can do, specifically the Robinson 22
because it's a pure helicopter, there is no augmentation
So today on Smarter Every Day, we're going to learn what goes into doing that
and what her brain is doing
It's really quite incredible
Let's go get Smarter Every Day
I'm going to be straight up with you
I'm convinced that helicopter instructor pilots are either complete idiots, or incredibly brave
I mean think about it
They get into a helicopter with someone they've never met
and give them the controls
(Destin) This is my first rotary -
(Brandon) crash course
No! I don't want to take a crash course
Notice that the controls are actually connected together
which means if I do something stupid
Brandon has to wrestle the controls out of my hand
Or just trust that I'm going to let go
That's crazy
Anyway, watch how bad I fly every single  time he gives me the controls -
- and you can easily tell when he takes back over
(Brandon) Almost got it, there you go
Pedal to your heading
(Brandon) laughs
(Destin) crap
(Destin) So I'm going to try that, we're going to taxi down
(Brandon)Yep
(Brandon) So you have the controls
(Destin) I have the controls
(Destin) okay you got it - laughs
(Brandon) Alright so you have the cyclic, alright just try to hold this in this spot
(Destin) Alright
(Brandon) Alright lets get us back over to that left...
(Destin) Good grief man
(Destin) Alright you're going to have to take over
(Destin) You got it?
(Brandon) Yep I got it
(Brandon) A little forward
(Destin) My bad
(Destin) Jeez...Whoop, let's don't hit that sign I say
(ATC Chatter) Destin and Brandon laugh
(Destin) Yep you have the craziest job in the world
(Brandon) Yep, it has it's ups and downs
(Brandon) Most...(laughs)...that's an awful joke
(Destin) So there is a moment when it clicks?
(Brandon) Yeah
(Destin) How long does it normally take?
(Brandon) 6 - 8 hours
Destin laughs
(Destin) How long is it going to take me?
(Brandon) 6 - 8 months
Destin and Brandon laugh
My next instructor was Tommy
We went in the R44 because the R22 was down for maintenance
I started to watch how they teach
And I noticed if I was starting to do something stupid their hands would get closer to the controls
- and when I was doing something easy, like flying straight and level, then they get more relaxed
Anyway, instructors call this part, when we're learning how to hover, the 'rodeo'
One of the best things that Tommy did for me was to teach me how to chill out
The thing I was doing was called a:
I was basically freaking out and over controlling, which made the whole aircraft wobble
Once I chilled, I was able to stabilise
Tommy got this to click in my brain by first teaching me how delicately to operate the controls
- and then showing me how two controls interact with each other
(Tommy) If you've moved the control, you've moved too much
(Destin) If you've moved the control...
(Tommy) Do you see what I'm saying though?
(Destin) Yeah
(Tommy) It's that whole thought process of it all
(Tommy) Alright, using the left pedal and only left pedal again, point me at that tree over there
(Destin) It's like...not even...a thought
(Tommy)Right! There you go, so something just clicked in your brain I can tell
(Destin) Okay
(Destin) Okay, I have collective, I have pedals, I'm going to try point at the stop sign -
- I'm going to raise and I'm going to keep pointing at the stop sign
(Tommy) Oh yeah, look something else just clicked
(Destin) So why do you have to move multiple controls to do one simple maneuver?
Turns out, THIS is the secret of hovering a helicopter
Okay, you've seen Rubik's cube solvers right? These guys that like have it stored somewhere in their brain stem
- and they can look at it and just instantly understand what they need to do right, to solve the thing
Well that's exactly what helicopter pilots are doing because if you think about it
- every time you change something, on a Rubik's cube, multiple inputs are changing all over the thing
It's a whole system, that's the way helicopters work
You have to come up with the most efficient and effective solution instantly to arrive at that perfect solution right of the bat
That's something you have to get in muscle memory somehow
Okay there are three main controls for a helicopter
The first one is what we call: collective
Collective is your power that you are applying to the rotor system
Basically the swash-plate moves together and it rotates those rotor blades so that they're taking more or less of a bite out of the air
Now if you think about that, when you do that it applies more torque or less torque to the body of the helicopter right
So you have to counter-act that with the pedals
When she moves the pedals back and forth, that, of course, gives you more or less counter-torque on the body of the whole aircraft
Another thing that you need to think about is that tail-rotor is blowing air, so it's pushing the whole helicopter to the side, right
- so the way you counteract that is what? Cyclic
Cyclic is similar to collective in that it moves the rotors in the swash-plate, only it does it independently
You can see that it is changing the swash-plate so that the rotors are moving independently of each other
What she has to do, is she has to take all three of these inputs, make them work together
Now imagine that happening several times a second, and you have kind of an idea of what's going on in Michelle's brain. Right?
(Destin) No?
(Michelle) This takes way more brain power
(Destin laughs)
Alright the next flight is with Michelle, who happens to be really sassy
When we got into the R22, she says "just so you know I'm a little bit more hands off"
Which basically meant if I got into a pilot induced oscillation she was going to make me recover
(Destin) Am I doing this or are you doing this?...Okay, thank you
(Michelle laughs)
I kind of didn't believe her though until she let me take off this horribly
(Destin)Golly
(Michelle laughing) That's one way to do it
(Destin laughing) You're awful
(Destin) So you ARE hands off
(Michelle) And we're off
(Destin laughs)
She basically forced me to straighten up by taking away my safety net, but I had gotten better really fast
(Michelle) I thought you said you sucked at this?
(Destin) Ah, I do suck at this
(Michelle) Eh, looks good to me
(Michelle) Alright you have the control
(Destin) So, first I'm going to take off, so that's the first thing you have to do?
(Destin) I'm teaching you how to do this now right
(Michelle laughs) I appreciate that
(Michelle) Perfect, there you go
(Destin) Alright...so there we are...we're hovering
(Michelle) We are hovering
(Destin) Poorly, but we are hovering
(Michelle) It's happening
(Destin) I want to try land over there
(Michelle) Okay
(Destin) And act like I know what I'm doing, even though I dont
(Michelle) I believe in you
(Destin) Okay, here we go
(Destin) I'm looking outside, looking outside, looking outside, looking outside
- I'm starting to commit, starting to commit, starting to commit, and we're down
(Destin) AH
(Michelle) I appreciate you teaching me that
(Destin laughs)
(Destin) Oh okay, I want to hold this...BOOM
(Michelle) Very nicely done
Okay so Brandon was crazy enough to start with me, and I decided to end with him so I could assess my progess
By this point I could take off, navigate to where-ever he wanted me, shoot an approach and even land
But remember, my goal was to be able to hover, and do it well
Brandon had a test for that
(Brandon) There is this stick over here, I want to see if you can land on it
(Destin) Oh you want me to land with the skids ON that stick?
(Brandon) Am I on it?
(Destin) Yeah you are!
(Brandon) I can't even...
(Destin) You're on it!...Impressive!
(Brandon) I want to see you put it down on that same spot
(Destin) Okay, is this like the test? If I can do this, then I...
(Brandon) You go solo right
(Destin) Dude! We're touching the stick
(Brandon laughs)
(Destin) BOOM! Touching the stick
(Destin) I'm very excited
(Destin) That's a big deal to me
(Brandon) Yeah, that's actually really good
- it just helps teach you precision
So there you go, hovering a helicopter is hilariously hard
I thought it was up for up, down for down, left and right
Oh no, it's a complex coupled control system and you have to rewire your brain to make it happen
It's pretty awesome
Anyway, thank you to the cities of St. Petersburg and Clearwater, Florida
They invited me down and sponsored this video to let me do this, it was amazing
I got to hover a helicopter, while my kids were playing on the beach below
That's amazing
Also there is plenty of other stuff you can do
They didn't tell me how to promote them so I'm just going to tell you what we did
We went to the Chihuly museum, which is one of the most famous glass artists in the world
There's a museum down there
Also the Salvador Dali museum
You know the guy, melting clocks, burning giraffes
There is a huge museum of nothing but awesome art
Also there's an MC Escher traveling exhibit when we were there
We got to meet Winter the Dolphin, you've heard of this dolphin
The dolphin that's missing its tail and they're working with it
We had a blast
If you are looking for a place to take a vacation please consider the St.Pete Clearwater Florida area
It's a great place just to go chill on the beach
If you get a chance, visit St. Pete Clearwater
Please consider it, I'll leave a link in the video description
Ah, thank you for sponsoring this, I appreciate that
Anyway, I'm Destin, you're getting Smarter Every Day, have a good one
(Destin) So you don't think hovering is like that?...well you're already messing it up I can tell you that right now
(Destin) Are you going to be a fixed wing instructor?
(Brandon) No, I have no desire to be a fixed wing instructor
(Destin) Why is that?
(Brandon) I don't like flying airplanes
- think about it...can you do this right here in an airplane?
(Destin) No
(Brandon) Alright then
We're here with Winter, the dolphin, at Clearwater Marine Aquarium and her trainers
- and your names are?
Cammy...and Julie
Alright and this is Winter's prosthetic tail
So this is were I practiced some helicopter maneuvers
And this is the Dali museum
(Destin) But you can do that with a helicopter quickly
(Destin and Michelle laugh)